foreign
it's called the greatest lie told during
covet and the one they will undoubtedly
try to tell again
so the LIE is as gato Malo argues in
this piece pandemics are dangerous to
Modern societies
now that's going to sound like an
extraordinary thing to call a lie isn't
it how could they not be we all know we
all know of pandemics like the one we're
supposedly still living in
um
and the Spanish flu and how you know how
completely dangerous they are but but he
he lays it out and I'm going to lay out
some of it and again I recommend that
you read the piece but let's just lay
out a few of the a few of the pieces
here what do we actually know
um well one of one of actually before I
before I lay it out in an organized way
one of the
um past pandemics of that last hundred
years uh that he points to is the Hong
Kong flu uh in 1968-69 uh which I had
actually not heard of except that we
were both born in 1969 and your mother
actually had it when she was pregnant
with you that's right right and it may
explain everything it may explain
everything absolutely
um but it was you know it was it was it
was pretty bad people were taking it
very seriously and yet what happened uh
near the near the Ender in the like in
the middle of
um of the Hong Kong flues so-called Hong
Kong flu uh being one of the worst
pandemics in America well Woodstock
happened right you know instead of the
response that we had during covid which
is shut down everything and um instill
fear and the hearts and minds of
everyone that you can possibly instill
fear in we let we let that's that's a
terrible way to put it but you know the
the American
government and the American people uh
apparently never considered or if they
ever considered it never got past some
very small meetings doing anything like
disrupting Society at the level that has
happened during coven Woodstock happened
one of the you know greatest known
public displays of sort of
um human extasis in the 20th century
right so
and what happened gosh well Woodstock
that's got to have been a super spreader
event well no it was fun right it was
fine so
um similarly as I was reading this piece
sort of before I lay out his argument
um he mentioned zika which was a virus
uh that shows up in South America as
something that causes if I remember
correctly micro encephaly uh in babies
born to mothers who exposed to zika
while they were pregnant and we were
about to go on our 11-week study abroad
with 30 students uh you know half of
whom were women and all of whom were
reproductive age and we had to we had to
we felt compelled we felt honor bound
and and that it was required of us to
talk carefully with all of them about
what this what we could tell about this
new emerging pathogen what the risks
were to them uh and
um to advise that if any of them were
actually thinking of you know getting
pregnant becoming mothers anytime soon
they should maybe considered not going
that it was you know that there there
seemed to be some kind of a some kind of
a latency and it was this emerging virus
we didn't know um but it was it was our
Our obligation to talk about what um
what that was and it seemed like it
might be something that would take over
the world and then it fizzled right like
people just stopped talking about it at
some point after some number of months
and this in part is the argument that
gato Malo is making that um these these
mostly
um
these these pandemics that we are told
to be terrified of
uh if there is no big governmental
response they tend to burn themselves
out
yeah that respiratory pathogens almost
never cause pandemics in the modern era
basically since penicillin that
penicillin and other antibiotics
depending on you know what the pathogen
is uh have uh have done a fantastic job
of controlling the kinds of things that
might once have actually done widespread
fast damage in human populations and
that is even when they appear to because
many maybe you want to actually maybe
you want to jump in here before I get
into the public policy measures so
effectively the argument is that there
is a trade-off things that spread highly
effectively aren't highly pathogenic
um or highly virulent and so
the point is yes things can spread
across civilization a respiratory virus
though requires you to as we've talked
about many times on Dark Horse it
requires you to be up and about in order
to do the spreading and therefore it
can't make you all that sick which means
it's not likely to be all that deadly
there are diseases that are exceptions
but they have other modes of
transmission and so so just to fill that
in if you if if you do not transmit
directly if the pathogen doesn't go from
host to host but uses a vector to get
between you something that is malaria
that is mosquito-borne for instance
mosquito Vector diseases like malaria
like yellow fever like West Nile like
Dengue may actually benefit from making
its host sick enough to be non-mobile
such that mosquitoes are better able to
find hosts and then carry them to other
not yet infected potential not only
not able to move around but uh you know
let's take Dengue yeah the colloquial
name break bone fever
um the reason because of the profound
pain in the bones in a it happens after
a person's been infected a second time
by Dengue so this is a
a complex phenomenon that involves
somebody who already has immunity which
the pathogen then utilizes but anyway
the point is oh you your bones feel like
they're broken well you're not very good
at swatting mosquitoes even if you know
you're lying flat right so anyway some
pathogens can be profoundly debilitating
and very dangerous and Dengue the second
time you get it is one of these
pathogens
um but and one at least one of the
species of malaria which there are four
uh right they these these diseases can
be very very uh very and they can kill
you and still win in at being the
disease that they are being the pathogen
that they are that causes the disease
whereas if you don't have
a vector or some other mechanism by
which to spread making your host very
very very sick so that they can't go out
and infect other people is an
evolutionary dead end for the pathogen
and so pathogens that do that won't
persist yeah
um the other thing to say and this is
proper context we've been fed and overly
simplistic model of all kinds of things
including the damage that comes from
pathogens for this entire pandemic one
of the things that happens even if you
had a comparatively High case fatality
rate in large measure what's happening
is those are its pulling deaths that
would occur soon so they happen sooner
than they might but the idea that we've
been sold is that somebody's life was
lost and that's not the right way to
think about it it's how many years of
life were lost right and which so you
might actually be able to see that if
you if you look at excess mortality for
you know five years before through ten
years after exactly see if you have less
than expected afterwards because you
some older people have already died a
year two three years before they might
have that is exactly right
um so anyway it's not it's not a simple
calculation and also if you were doing
something like comparing unknown Harms
from a transfection agent and you know
an untried gene therapy uh and a disease
with an unknown risk to human life
if the risk is to young people then the
number of years lost for every life lost
is huge right whereas when somebody is
dying of covid and they are at their
life expectancy or Beyond it they're
losing very few years and these things
should it's not a difficult thing to
calculate the amount of loss we just
refuse to do it because something
wanted us to think these were deaths as
if these people were going to live
forever uh you know absent the virus
when in fact what mostly happened was
people who were very old or quite sick
had some years potentially lost but uh
not a huge number
so the argument continues again this is
in the bad catitude sub stack piece that
I will link to that many public policy
measures like lockdowns and
um although this isn't a public policy
measure this is a widespread medical
measure particularly in some places like
New York the use of ventilators
lockdowns ventilators
did more harm than good
and many if not most of
if if not maybe even the vast majority
of covet deaths during covid are
attributable to what Brett was just
talking about with regard to hastening
the demise of someone who was already
near the end of their life which doesn't
make it a wonderful thing to have
happened but it's less tragic than when
a child dies or a young person dies
um
but even
um you know if we look at 2020 before
the the transfectionations before the
so-called vaccines were charted out at
which point
um we have other reasons to um consider
what excess deaths are about uh the the
argument laid out here is that many of
the
um
many of the harms many of the excess
deaths and other injuries that people
were experiencing were iatrojack and
iatrogenic means and I'm just going to
read exactly the definition uh that that
he writes in his book is relating in his
book in his sub stack relating to
illness caused by medical examination or
treatment
so if what we have
are largely harms caused not by the
pathogen but by the treatment
brought on in order to treat the
pathogen then certainly it could have
been avoided and there's a lot of
evidence that comes in a variety of
forms in this in this piece including
for instance that Sweden which almost
uniquely in the west
responded very quickly very early in a
couple of ways but then mostly just let
its Society be and a lot of people in
the west were confused I mean I was
confused like wow that's that's amazing
what are they doing I would have
expected Sweden and all the rest of the
Scandinavian countries to be doing sort
of what the US is doing but more so and
the fact is that what they did worked
and what they did was not much they let
Society be right they let Society do
what it in what it was supposed to be
doing and
uh specifically ventilators in the
ventilators which were widespread in
icus in New York and not in several
other states uh correlate uh you you see
extremely high death rates During the
period when ventilators were being used
on coveted patients and icus in New York
and not at the same time controlling for
almost everything except the exact
location in these other states where
ventilators weren't being used that
suggests that the ventilators were the
cause
the primary cause rather than the covid
you have of course
um
sending coveted positive people into
Care Homes where you know Care Homes are
already people who are who are at risk
or because of um because of their age
because they are somewhat infirm because
they're not being allowed to go outside
because they're not moving much you send
coveted positive people into Care Homes
you spread covid and some of those
people are not going to make it and
keeping people inside rather than
letting people go outside and be active
and be healthy and make D while the sun
shines and do all the things that we're
supposed to be doing outside of course
was another iatrogenic harm as a
resultant harm from during covid which
can be attributed to not the virus but
the policy in response to the virus and
then we'll talk about Spanish Flu in a
moment but you have some things to say
yeah I have a number of things to say
here
one
there is a question
the deaths occurred as a result of
medical treatment that was a mistake or
it may have been a mistake I think the
ventilators for instance the ventilators
yes the ventilators for instance sending
sick people to Care Homes all of these
things had a negative impact well I was
I was just saying with regard to a
mistake I hope that the ventilator use
was a mistake I cannot fathom how
sending sick people into Care Homes ever
made yeah
the Striking thing about our Behavior at
a medical level during covid was that we
did essentially everything we shouldn't
have done and none of the things we
should have done right people should
have been outside we locked them inside
we took sick people and sent them to
places they would infect other
vulnerable people we hooked them up to
ventilators when the ventilators didn't
work we turned up the pressure right we
denied them drugs that are safe and do
work
we gave them things Medical Treatments
that don't work and cause harm it's
across the board and I keep trying to
call attention to the unlikeliness of
you landing on every wrong answer that's
really improbable right
um so I don't know whether that is just
a matter of we have a few morons who
think upside down and land on the wrong
answer all the time and really all you
got to do to find out the right answers
do the opposite of whatever they say
that seems super unlikely but could be
but the point is
um we did all these things whatever
their nature they caused a lot of people
to die and then we counted them as Cova
deaths and so the counting them as covet
deaths then amped up the Panic help
Stoke fear right and the Panic then
Justified the Draconian measures that
were inflicted on us so again I don't
know
how this worked or why it happened but
gato malo's point is we inflicted this
harm on ourselves it caused a lot of
fear because it created numbers that
left the impression of an extremely
dangerous virus now of course you and I
believe that the virus is very
destructive but it doesn't have a high
case fatality rate and so the fear that
it was going to rob us of you know our
friends and relatives at some high rate
was always nonsense but we created this
fictional pathogen that was doing that
and those had there been a force behind
the scenes that had been looking for an
excuse to increase its own power to
control the behavior of the population
what could be said where people could go
this became that excuse and it deployed
it at an incredible rate
the other thing from the points you've
uh you've highlighted so far that I
thought was very strong
in this piece was it suggests that in
some sense as bad as a disease that's
circulating in society is and I think we
under rate the harm of all the things
that circulate but as bad as they are
it may be that the best thing you can do
is as little as possible you can treat
the symptoms you can take you know basic
rational precautions you isolate very
sick people yeah if you're sick don't
make contact with other people and wash
your hands these sorts of things you
know you can treat uh acute cases if
you've got a really good safe drug that
seems to prevent it transmission when
one person in the household gets it you
could give that drug to the others you
know and there are all sorts of basic
things you could do but the new virus is
at the moment to introduce other new
medical technology or is that not the
moment that's the amazing thing and uh
the last thing I want to say at this
stage in the discussion is
we have two basic models of medicine in
competition and I believe that we saw
something like a coup unfold by one
against the other during the covet
pandemic
who was by the public health approach to
the medical health approach
now
I certainly agree that there are
questions to be raised about public
health there are things that happen at
the population level that matter that
are not best addressed at the personal
level however personal medical health
with respect to illnesses that an
individual comes down with
are
comparatively well addressed from a
bottom-up approach that is to say
doctors seeing patients discovering what
works what doesn't work talking with
each other improving their own
techniques pooling their information
right that system but treating patients
as individuals right not as uh
temporarily disaggregated members of
some vague population doctors don't
treat populations doctors treat
individuals individuals and pools of
doctors get smarter because
a doctor who sees a pattern will discuss
that pattern with other doctors who will
decide whether they are seeing that
pattern and what it might mean that
emergent intelligence grows in medicine
and what has happened here is we have
decided instead that we what we want is
the highest quality information sourced
by the people in the position to see the
most who will then hand down the
information about the standard of care
and in this case they handed us every
wrong idea there was they did massive
harm whereas Dar and they and they and
they they hey they basically
um
they handcuffed the doctors who
otherwise would have done much better
and so anyway the comparison between a
bottom-up approach doctors seeing
patients and discovering what works
versus a top-down approach where Anthony
fauci tells you what he was given on the
tablets on the mountain and this thing
right there's no comparison between
these in terms of how much harm was
going to be done we tried during covid
we tried the Anthony fauci version and
we got an absolutely unmitigated
disaster we got a disaster that we
Amplified
[Music]
oh